>>> AS A HOMEOWNER, YOU NEVER
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO GO WRONG.
>> I WANTED TO GIVE HIM A BATH.
>> LUCKILY, STATE FARM HAS YOU
COVERED NO MATTER WHAT THE
ISSUE.
WITH THE STATE FARM APP, YOU CAN
FILE A CLAIM IN SECONDS SO YOU
CAN GET BACK TO YOUR LIFE.
>> WOW, THAT WAS EASY.
THANKS, JAKE FROM STATE FARM.
>> LIKE A GOOD NEIGHBOR, STATE
FARM IS THERE.
>> GUESS I WON'T BE LATE FOR
WORK AFTER ALL.
>> ONE MORE THING.
IS THIS DRYER SAFE.
>> BY, HON.
>> HAVE A GREAT DAY.
HEY, DO YOU WANT A CUP OF
COFFEE?
>> I WOULD LOVE ONE.
>> NO MATTER WHAT YOUR INSURANCE
NEEDS, STATE FARM HAS A POLICY
FOR YOU.
>> HELLO?
OH, JAKE FROM STATE FARM.
YOU'RE STILL HERE.
>> UNLIKE OTHER INSURANCE
COMPANIES, STATE FARM IS HERE
FOR YOU 24/7.
>> RIGHT.
SO WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR DINNER?
>> OH, JAKE AND THE KIDS AND I
WENT OUT FOR PIZZA.
BUT THERE SHOULD BE STUFF IN THE
FRIDGE TO MAKE A SANDWICH.
>> BOOM, BOOM, BOOM.
>> TEXT ME WHEN YOU GET HOME.
>> I WILL.
>> AND IN SPORTS, THE BLUE JAYS
AND YANKEES MEET TONIGHT FOR THE
DECIDING GAME.
>> WHOA.
LOOK WHO'S UP, SLEEPY HEAD.
THINK FAST.
>> HEY.
WHERE THE HELL WERE YOU?
>> JAKE AND I TOOK THE KIDS TO
CHURCH.
>> TO CHURCH?
>> YES, TO CHURCH.
AND I HAPPEN TO AGREE.
NOW EXCUSE ME.
>> YOU'RE GETTING IT.
YOU'RE A NATURAL.
GIVE ME SOME.
>>> LIKE A GOOD NEIGHBOR, STATE
FARM IS THERE.
>> SOME HEAT.
>> STATE FARM IS THERE.
>> I TAKE THE INSURANCE CLAIM.
STATE FARM IS THERE.
>> STATE FARM IS THERE.
>> YOU LOOKING FOR BETTER RATES?
STATE FARM IS THERE.
>> JESUS.
>> YOU LOOKING FOR BETTER RATES?
>> YOU KNOW YOU WON'T FIND THEM.
>> JESUS.
STATE FARM IS RATE MATCHED EVEN
>> YOU KNOW YOU WON'T FIND THEM.
IF YOU DO FIND CHEAPER COVERAGE,
STATE FARM IS RATE MATCHED EVEN
WE'LL JUST MATCH IT.
IF YOU DO FIND CHEAPER COVERAGE,
>> THIS IS MY HOUSE, AND I WANT
WE'LL JUST MATCH IT.
HIM GONE.
>> THIS IS MY HOUSE, AND I WANT
HE IS NOT A GOOD NEIGHBOR!
HIM GONE.
>> GET YOUR FINGER OUT OF MY
HE IS NOT A GOOD NEIGHBOR!
FACE!
>> GET YOUR FINGER OUT OF MY
>> SAVE EVEN MORE WHEN YOU
FACE!
BUNDLE HOME AND AUTO.
>> SAVE EVEN MORE WHEN YOU
SLEEP TIGHT.
BUNDLE HOME AND AUTO.
STATE FARM IS WITH YOU 24/7.
SLEEP TIGHT.
>> I JUST WANTED A POLICY!
STATE FARM IS WITH YOU 24/7.
LIKE A GOOD NEIGHBOR, STATE FARM
>> I JUST WANTED A POLICY!
IS THERE, AND HERE AND IN MY BED
LIKE A GOOD NEIGHBOR, STATE FARM
WITH MY WIFE!
IS THERE, AND HERE AND IN MY BED
HE TOOK EVERYTHING, EVERYTHING!
WITH MY WIFE!
>> STEP AWAY FROM THE EDGE.
HE TOOK EVERYTHING, EVERYTHING!
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS, BUDDY
>> STEP AWAY FROM THE EDGE.
♪ LIMU EMU ♪
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS, BUDDY
AND DOUG.
♪ LIMU EMU ♪
>> LIMU AND I CAN HELP SNOENT
AND DOUG.
LIBERTY, LIBERTY, LIBERTY ♪